hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
a fox news poll finding 46 percent of
american respondents
feel president biden is too liberal up
10
since the end of 2019 co-founder and
president of real clear politics tom
bevin weighs in on the polling data
and ongoing negotiations over president
biden's infrastructure plan
a 32-year annual tradition returns this
holiday weekend
actor and co-host of the national
memorial day concert
gary sinise joins the rundown to discuss
this year's star-studded event
and how it will honor veterans first
responders and other
american heroes plus commentary from
syndicated columnist
and fox news contributor cal thomas the
fox news rundown is a daily news podcast
where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm janis dean i'm david asman i'm dana
parino and this
is the fox news rundown
friday may 28 2021 i'm jessica rosenthal
the president is expected to propose a
massive budget plan today
the question though is how much support
can he get from lawmakers
and from voters for everything that you
you know make a concession for to
republicans that's going to anger some
folks
on the left will in the house or the
senate and cause them to
you know get throw up a roadblock
i'm chris foster the national memorial
day concert sunday night once again
hosted by the actor gary sinise
you know i just can't imagine not being
part of this concert
uh and i'm glad that we're carrying on
even
even in light of the pandemic and not
being able to do it live
on the lawn of the capitol and i'm cal
thomas i've got the final word on the
fox news rundown
[Music]
president biden is expected to unveil a
roughly six
trillion dollar budget plan today for
the next fiscal year
analysts say under these spending plans
the national debt would surpass the
record level set after world war ii
while higher taxes are meant to help pay
for it all it will take more than a
decade for those to offset this spending
and until then annual deficits will soar
we've already heard a lot about what the
president wants to spend on with the
american jobs plan and the american
family's plan
and while republicans have said a lot of
what democrats are calling
infrastructure
is not infrastructure there is some
movement on possibly reaching
some kind of deal west virginia
republican senator shelly moore capito
said the full senate passed a water
infrastructure package
worth 35 billion dollars and this week
the environment and public works
committee
we passed a 316 trillion dollar
five-year surface transportation bill it
has a lot of
things that the president wants in there
president biden said thursday before
boarding air force one
he's hopeful for even more i had a good
conversation very brief
but a good conversation with capito
senator and i told her we would uh
she's going to contact me next week i
told her we have to finish this
really soon there is a lot more in the
president's spending plan the question
is how much will he get passed
will there be deal making on other items
like national paid leave and
universal pre-k senate minority leader
mitch mcconnell had said he was 100
percent focused on stopping the
administration
later clarifying that he's anxious to
stop the president depending upon the
issue
on infrastructure republicans are making
counteroffers
look if biden wants to if he wants to
back up his rhetoric
by about being a bipartisan leader and
a uniter and all that this is the
perfect opportunity for him to do that
tom bevin is the president and
co-founder of real clear politics
he could if he were to accept this offer
i think he might be able to get enough
republicans to get something now he's
going to lose some democrats probably
and
right and then the focus shifts to the
house and how many republicans he can
win there
versus how many of the progressive
caucus that he would lose or nancy
pelosi would lose
uh so and her margins are very very thin
over there so
i'm still skeptical uh but i think if
they agreed on if they got to an
agreement on a number
that uh you know republicans at least at
least some of them were comfortable with
it's possible
but i'm still skeptical that something's
gonna get done
because it doesn't seem the political
incentives are
are enough in line to make this thing
happen
even now okay we're gonna get into the
political incentives in a bit but
we know a big part of what the president
wants to spend on is
infrastructure and we've also heard for
years that is something republicans can
get behind as you just referenced
what do we know about what's in the
competing
proposals like what's being taken out of
the white house proposal to come down
from that two trillion
plus number and what's in the senate
republican proposal that they've added
in to bring it up from that 568 billion
so republicans initially started out uh
by saying look we just want to fund sort
of what is traditional infrastructure
right we remember the debate the bite
administration said everything's
infrastructure now right
you know uh home care and uh
you know daycare and all these things um
and republicans
came with their initial offer saying
look it's just roads it's just bridges
it's just airports and that's it
now republicans have um you know
in their new offer they have increased
their spending on
those typical things but also added uh
you know monies for you know water
uh broadband those kinds of things which
traditionally
they haven't included as infrastructure
so i think in that sense biden sort of
you know his his opening gambit of
calling everything infrastructure
did move the window a little bit and
and bring some republicans along
uh to compromise on the idea that there
are some things outside of roads and
bridges and airports that
they can be considered infrastructure
and that are good
uh you know public works projects that
will benefit people so
um republicans have come up there and
and democrats
um you know they've they've managed to
i think come off the idea that
absolutely everything is infrastructure
and so
that's where the compromise can
potentially be reached well you
we turn to you a lot to crunch numbers
and look at data what what are you
seeing across
really um the spectrum of polling that
you look at i guess in aggregate you
know about
how americans feel about the idea of
spending this much money
and not just on infrastructure right
like on things like universal pre-k
child care the expanded child tax credit
you know things that
as you referenced um are in some cases
being called infrastructure but
previously maybe weren't
it's interesting and and this is one of
those situations where you really have
to
tease out what's you know behind the
numbers because it depends on
how the questions are worded right
because i mean
who doesn't you know when you say like
uh you ask a question
do you want clean water of course
everyone wants clean water right it's
easy
do you want you know uh do you want more
spending
on airports and roads and bridges so the
idea of spending money on
on infrastructure is popular um the idea
of
of spending money on all of these
different proposals is
fairly popular and then the question
becomes well how do you pay for that and
who's going to pay for it
and and while there is support for
biden's
uh his pay fors which are raising tax
rates
uh on corporations and those making more
than four hundred thousand dollars a
year
you know beyond that there was a harvard
harris poll that just came out mark penn
uh did a podcast i was just listening to
earlier talking about how in his numbers
he found only
25 percent of folks are approve of
raising taxes in general
um so there are some fault lines where
these things while they're
while on the surface they look popular
and people say of course we want you
know
shiny bridges and airports um when
when you dig underneath the numbers a
little bit it is
uh it becomes much more complex and not
quite as clear-cut
in terms of uh how people are going to
ultimately view this
tell me about what the data also shows
about this because i
i don't know i haven't seen any recent
polling data on this but
have we asked americans how do you feel
about an annual deficit being 1.8
trillion how do you feel about
you know the growing national debt of
over what like 30 trillion dollars now
um does that factor into people's
decisions especially when you know let's
say 2022 rolls around midterms roll
around
do people think in those terms because
those that seems far away right
or is it more like hey your your
immediate spending has immediately
caused
inflation and that's hurting my bank
account
you know what i mean do people react i
imagine people would react more to
the immediacy of their finances rather
than
the future debt or deficit that's right
it's it's
it's uh it's very much you know
the the debt and deficit look people
don't
they don't like that necessarily but it
is one of those things it's in the
abstract it is not
a concrete thing that is happening right
now
and the idea that you know if we had to
pay the debt
and deficit back tomorrow and we had to
cut all these programs
then people would be like wait what are
you talking about i you know i don't get
my social security i don't get all these
benefits because
because we owe all this money it would
become a very real thing but it
it very much is in the abstract but to
your point
when it when it becomes a drag on
the economy it becomes uh
you know it triggers inflation and it
starts to really impact people
by you know increased prices of gas and
now we're talking about prices of
lumber which leads and we've got a you
know red hot housing market
so it's tougher for people to you know
find places to live and like
um and their paychecks aren't going as
far because food costs more
that becomes and people see that in
their daily lives then then it is an
absolute
uh becomes a real uh immediate
uh crisis let's talk a little bit about
how all of this gets passed right how
any of this spending gets passed because
the president has said he does not want
a deficit spend he does want to raise
taxes
republicans have said no we have heard a
little bit of talk about a possible 25
corporate tax rate talk to me about how
some of this
spending might get passed without
republican support
um in terms of reconciliation how that
might work i know there's there's a
limit on the number of times you can
use reconciliation right there is
although
there appear to be loopholes i mean
chuck schumer is like finding them
you know under the couch cushions and
whatnot um
so but they could do this
via reconciliation um part of it this is
the
this is the other part of the equation
right it's coming to agreement okay
what's the number
what what can we agree on that we should
be spending stuff on
uh and then and then how do you pay for
it and you're right i mean
uh republicans are not enthusiastic
about
going back on the trump tax cuts and
raising corporate rates and
uh all these different things so that
that is also going to be is another
reason that i'm
i'm not very
optimistic that there's going to be any
bipartisan agreement on this because you
just can't get
enough agreement uh on the republican
side
and then again it's it's it's one of
those things for everything that you you
know make a concession for to
republicans that's going to anger some
folks
on the left in the house or the senate
and cause them to
you know get throw up a roadblock
or or whatever and until you know the
devil's going to be in the details and
until
these guys can all agree on something um
you know it's going to be very very hard
to find out you raise the money
necessary to make the investments that
that you know joe biden wants to make
let's look ahead
uh 2022 because it's always about
winning elections right
and i wonder about these moves
when you when you see republicans and
democrats sort of saying
no we want to we want to come together
we want to do a deal um
but then one side gets worried that the
other side
claims the win right and you want to be
able to go into your election
into your race um either saying like i
reached across the aisle you know some
people in congress
really seem like they they like saying
that line like i'm a i'm somebody who
reaches across the island gets the
gets the deal done but then you see
others
who use the opposite language like nope
we're gonna we're gonna
block this we're gonna stand firm you
know we're not doing this
does it depend on the issue like is
infrastructure one of those things that
everyone might be happy to walk away and
say they they
won like if even if it was a republican
and or a democrat everybody wins
or is it not dependent on the issue is
it dependent on the district is it
dependent on the congress person
and who their constituents are that they
block everything no matter what
traditionally congress people have
have wanted compromise and they have
wanted to be able to go back
to their voters and say look
i'm working on your behalf and here are
the things that i helped do i help
sponsor these bills i help
bring this money back to the district
that you know helps help put that park
over there and that
you know new school over there or
whatever the case may be
but increasingly as we have seen
the midterms are are nationalized
around in this in this very polarized
environment and so
you know i don't i don't think a lot of
these members are as worried about going
back to voters
in 2022 and saying you know i did all
these things
they could be perfectly fine saying look
i'm trying to protect you from the this
radical administration joe biden said he
was going to be
a centrist and a moderate he's not
operating like that
and so you know i'm standing there in
the middle with my hand out and nobody
is reaching out to shake it
and i will continue to do that and you
know that's not necessarily a bad
message
uh for for republicans in 2022
so in that sense maybe the incentives
are lined up to be more
more in favor of of you know if they
can't get a deal they're comfortable
with going back to their constituents
no deal is better than than you know
some sort of compromise deal
that that um may not look so good back
home
well tom bevin thank you so much for
your time absolutely great to be with
you
this is cal thomas with your fox news
commentary coming up
the national memorial day concert
started in 1989 as a way to honor and
remember those who've given their lives
for our country and to express
appreciation for all veterans and troops
serving now
besides the music there are tributes and
real life stories from throughout our
nation's military history
the show used to be and will be again a
free concert on the west lawn of the
united states capitol building
last year and this year because of the
coronavirus pandemic the show has been
produced using
pre-taped segments and performances well
it's
you know where we look at this as an
opportunity to do something
a little bit different than the folks at
capitol concerts really
know how to do this show gary sinise is
back as co-host of the concert it airs
sunday night may 30th on pbs streaming
online
and on the american forces network
around the world
whether we're on the lawn of the capitol
uh or not
uh it's going to be a great show they
have tremendous
cast great entertainers that are part of
the show this year
as always i mean they always have some
fantastic people but
this year it's going to be just great no
matter what so i
encourage everybody to tune in may 30th
and on pbs
and and watch what we're doing it's 90
minutes of
salute and tribute to the men and women
who have served and sacrificed
for our country it's really a special
special concert
yeah looking at the lineup here the
music lineup the national symphony
orchestra of course
for country fans there's vince gill and
alan jackson there's
the four tops and gladys knight so
plenty uh plenty of great music even if
it's not in front of a live audience now
gary besides the music there are three
stories being presented during the
broadcast
uh there's a tribute to the nurses of
the vietnam war now 11
000 american women were stationed in
vietnam over the course of that war and
some of them died right
well yeah um the you know we always
personalize
uh you know the larger conflict through
telling the story of of individuals who
serve during a particular
moment uh conflict and we have a
a story of a 21 year old nurse can you
imagine being 21 years old
serving as a nurse in a battlefield in
vietnam
the types of things that that one would
see and experience
and and the bonds that were created
between
uh all the nurses at that time uh there
were
you know it's like over 200 000 i think
it's
265 000 women served during
the vietnam era so so many
uh we we tell a story of
one of the nurses uh diane carlson evans
who uh
she's actually the the founder of the
vietnam women's memorial in washington
dc
and we tell her story she was 21 when
she served over there
and that very personal single story
represents the thousands of women who
served
in vietnam and the thousands of nurses
and the bonds that were created between
all of them
it's really uh going to be a wonderful
segment and we
we have you know many wonderful segments
coming up this is
after all the 20th anniversary of the
september 11th attacks
and my co-host joe montana his first
year with the show was 2002
the the following year after
the september 11th attacks and they did
a segment about
several firefighters who had lost sons
on that day and joe was one of the
actors who
did that particular segment and that
solidified joe's commitment to the
concert
and a few years later he invited me to
come and
be a part of it i was doing a lot of uso
work and
i was taking my band around the country
and overseas to the war zones and that
kind of thing
and uh they did a segment on the uso
in that particular show and they wanted
me to come and be a part of it with my
band so i did but i also narrated
some of the segments in the following
year jill uh
and uh jerry colbert the producer they
asked me uh
to co-host the show and that was 2005
that i brought my band in 2006 i started
co-hosting with joe and i've been doing
it
ever since and every year we
you know there are so many different
stories that we tell
and every year it's it's like we can't
possibly top this show and it's the best
one we've ever done
and this is the 32nd year of the show
i know it's going to be equally as good
if not better than
than all the other ones but it's hard
every year it's fantastic they just do a
fantastic job with the show
well joe i read um said uh that he may
have come first but that you are the
gold standard when it comes to hosting
this kind of thing he says that he is
the sparrow to your eagle
he's goofy yeah my
my wing man yeah yeah joe's great he's a
great friend he
he loves our our military he loves our
troops
uh he's an ambassador for my foundation
the gary sinise foundation
and has been for many years uh joe's
jose uh you know i i always can count on
joe
if if i need something to help my
foundation along
ambassador go out represent somewhere
because i can't be there or something
like that joe
is as solid as they come he's a
wonderful wonderful friend we both had
uncles who served in world war
ii uh we've just been bonded uh for many
many years
you know we knew each other 40 years ago
but it was really
the collective coming together at the
national memorial day concert that
just solidified our friendship
uh in in a way and and now
you know i just can't imagine not being
part of this concert
and i'm glad that we're carrying on even
even in light of the pandemic and not
being able to do it live on the lawn
of the capitol you mentioned your
foundation i was about to ask you about
it um it's to help veterans and first
responders 10 years old now right
we uh we're coming up on the end of our
10th year
uh june 30th uh june 30th
2011 i launched the foundation publicly
at a big event at the national press
club in washington dc
and that's when our website went live
and we
uh started asking for donations uh
from the american people and over the
course of the last 10 years our programs
have expanded
the support from the american people has
expanded and and
now we're you know we've just raised
hundreds of millions of dollars
to support the men and women who serve
our country um
we last year we had to shut down a lot
of our travel because of the pandemic
but it didn't slow us down at all
we kind of shifted uh some of the things
that we were doing
and we we created a fundraising campaign
called the
the emergency coverage 19 combat service
we raised almost a million and a half
dollars
just for first responders and medical
workers
and we've supported just countless
organizations and hospitals and first
responder departments
across the country over the years
yeah i've talked to a lot of people over
this over the pandemic who have
foundations or charities and they say
look it's been a really tough year so
you're saying you actually it wasn't
that bad for you guys
uh you know uh one of the things that we
we wondered
back in march of 2020
was what's going to happen to the to our
funding you know
our you know people are worried about
the economy uh
is the funding for are the funding
sources going to dry up or what's going
to happen
and there's two things that could have
happened people could have
held on to their money and been uh you
know very
protective of that because of the
economy the other the other thing that
could happen is that people wanted to be
a part of the fight
and so often the way to do that is by
supporting non-profits who are
operating in these areas and
we support first responders military
folks
we expanded to health care workers and
hospitals
we worked with the military hospitals
all the time so we ended up
supporting about 90 different va's
across the country
so we just expanded our efforts
and we found that that a lot of people
wanted to find
some way to be a part of the fight
against this pandemic and what was going
on in our country and
so we were able to continue on and do
really well and
you know it's always an ongoing effort
when you're talking about a non-profit
where we're asking
the american people to support us but i
think if you want to support veterans
we're one way to do that and
health care workers and first responders
you can go to the gary sinise foundation
website and you can go to the national
memorial day concert
website as well where several
non-profits
supporting veterans are listed on the
website gary real quick uh the film and
tv production look like it's
starting to really storm back um have
you had a chance to
get any work done your friends have you
heard anything about what it's like on a
set these days
yeah there's a lot of coven 19 protocols
and everything like that but a lot of
productions are
you know just firing away and and
getting a lot done
uh it's just a little bit different than
it used to be and they create these
bubbles and things like that
i don't know what's going to happen now
that things are loosening up and
things are coming more under control and
you know
all this stuff but i i've just been
focused on
my foundation work and and things here
at home
uh lately uh you know eventually i'll
i'll get back to something
gary sneese actor founder of the gary
sneese foundation co-host with joe
montagne of the pbs national memorial
day concert that's also streaming on
youtube and facebook so plenty of ways
to see it gary thanks for coming on
congratulations on another great year of
the concert
thanks so much for having me
new from the fox news podcast network my
name is kennedy and welcome to
my podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome
it's kennedy saves the world subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
ohio's covet 19 vaccine incentive
program
is paying off big that's the program in
which permanent ohio residents who are
adults and get at least one shot of a
covit 19 vaccine are eligible to win a
million dollars
younger folks are also getting in on the
winning and those aged 12 to 17 who get
coveted shots
are eligible to win a full-ride
scholarship to any state school in ohio
it's also inspired similar vaccine
incentive lotteries in colorado
maryland new york state and oregon
abigail buginski is ohio's first
million dollar winner i was completely
surprised when i got the call
and i'm i still can't believe it joseph
costello who just finished eighth grade
is the first college scholarship winner
his mom colleen says she was overwhelmed
upon hearing the news
i was really thankful at that moment
that there was a bench nearby because
i needed to sit down the vaccine lottery
seems to be working too
the number of people in ohio age 16 and
older who received their initial coven
19 vaccine
jumped 33 percent in the week after the
state announced its million-dollar
incentive lottery
according to an associated press
analysis so far
more than two and a half million ohio
adults have signed up for the million
dollar prize
and more than 104 000 kids age 12 to 17
entered the drawing for the college
scholarship
which covers tuition room and board and
books
more winners will be announced in each
contest on wednesdays
through june 23rd tanya j powers fox
[Music]
news
it's time for your fox news commentary
cal
thomas what's on your mind secretary of
homeland security alejandro mayorkas is
reportedly considering the development
of tools that would help america's
children
discern truth from lies and know when
they are being fed
disinformation the washington times
which first reported the story
says a department spokesperson declined
to give details but that more
information would be revealed in the
coming weeks
majorcas might want to start by fact
checking his recent claim that the u.s
southern border is
closed he made the statement when news
pictures showed waves of people crossing
the border
should kids believe him or their lying
eyes should anyone regardless of
political party or persuasion
be comfortable with government telling
especially children what they can
believe and whom they can trust
this is what totalitarian states do it's
called
propaganda we're already inundated with
political correctness
cancel culture and wokism tv networks
spend more time
delivering opinion and slanting stories
to particular points of view
than what once resembled if not
objective journalism then at least
fairness
the list of government officials who
have lied is long and dates back to the
founders of the nation
some lies could be defended on national
security grounds
others were used to cover up wrongdoing
or enhance the image of the one who lied
george orwell was prescient when he
wrote in 1984 about new speak in the
ministry of truth
we have already achieved the former and
what we are allowed to say or not say
lest we be smeared with nasty rhetorical
stains
let's revisit the ministry of truth for
those who haven't read the book or need
a reminder
the ministry of truth was related to
newspeak in that it had nothing to do
with truth
but propaganda by another name its job
was to falsify historical records in
ways that align with government policies
and its version of those events it was
also
tasked with defining truth which
sometimes resulted in double speak
or contradictions that served the
purposes of the state
truth has become subjective and relative
in modern times and is now personal
you have your truth and i love fox news
click the subscribe button to get more
of the news and opinion you trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes